Agreeable young woman to be more disagreeable and assertive if that isn't how
she is temperamentally inclined.
Oh,
that's a good question.
And I would say first of all,
that's a very common question that people who go into psychotherapy ask.
I think the most common problem that psychotherapists deal with apart from
anxiety and depression is probably assertiveness training.
Um,
so the first thing I would say is you really need to figure out what you want.
And I would recommend doing the self authoring program,
the future authoring program in particular because if you want to stand up for
yourself,
you have to have your goals and your vision well laid out and well defined.
And then you have to have a strategy,
um,
that that is matched to those goals so that you can,
so that you know what you want so that you know when you're not getting it it
otherwise you're left with a vague sense of dissatisfaction and resentment.
And that's very,
very difficult thing to articulate.
And if you can't articulate it,
then you can't negotiate.
If you know what you want and you know why,
then you can make a case for yourself.
Okay.
So let's assume now that you've laid out a vision and a counter vision,
which the future authoring program also helps you do.
So you know what kind of hell you want to avoid that you might drift into if you
were to agreeable for the rest of your life.
And that would be a hell that consisted mostly of people taking advantage of you
all the time and you feeling resentful and bitter about it.
Not something I would recommend.
Um,
see,
I think that women are agreeable because it helps them deal with infants,
but it's not a great temperamental strategy for dealing with complex,
um,
organizations in,
in the adult world.
So I think it's a price that women pay for.
Also being adapted to have plenty of patients for very young children.
And then you have to overcome that to some degree to put yourself forward
properly in more complex hierarchies of accomplishment.
So I would say once you have your vision established,
your vision for the future and your counter vision,
so you're afraid of what will happen.
If you don't stand up for yourself,
then you need to consult your resentment fic.
Because if you're resentful about something,
as far as I can tell,
there's generally only two reasons.
One is you should grow the hell up and quit whining,
so you've got to find out first.
If you're just feeling sorry for yourself and you can think that through,
make a pro and con case and you can talk to somebody that you care about about
that.
I'm not assuming that that's the reason,
but that's one potential reason.
If you're not merely feeling sorry for yourself,
then you probably have something to say and something that you need and you need
to figure out what that is and then you have to develop a strategy to to put
that forward.
I've seen lots of people in my personal life and in my private practice not get
what they want because well a,
they don't specify it and they don't ask for it.
And if you're negotiating save for a raise or for a promotion and so forth,
you have to put yourself forward.
You need to tell your the person you're working for,
why you should be treated with more consideration or respect or have more
resources devoted to you or more authority.
Um,
what shifted to you?
And you have to make a case for that.
A compelling case so that they have a reason to attend to you.
And that's not good.
They're not going to notice because most managerial types are so overloaded with
work that they never noticed when anything's going right.
They just notice the things that are going wrong.
So you need to make a plan,
you have to have a strategy that goes along with that plan.
You have to have articulated arguments for why certain a certain form of
treatment is appropriate to you.
And then you have to have the courage to put that forward.
And I guess you have to remember that you owe yourself as much as you owe other
people.
You have to take care of yourself,
like you take care of other people and,
and that's a moral duty and if you practice that,
you can do it.
And a lot of that,
a lot of that is also associated with telling the truth.
You know,
you don't have a better friend than the truth,
even though it can be very harsh in the short term.
And so if you're unhappy at work because you're being taken advantage of,
then you have to strategize yourself out of that and you have to learn to
negotiate.
And a lot of that also means that you have to overcome your hesitancy to engage
in conflict.
And you've got to think about it this way.
Negotiation and conflict are somewhat indistinguishable and it's easy moment to
moment to avoid negotiation conflict,
but you pay a terrible price for it in the medium to long term.
It's better to face the conflict forthrightly in the present and make peace for
the medium to long term.
And that there's courage in that.
So that's the other thing I would say is gird up your loins and,
and,
and allow yourself to act courageously,
courageously.
And truthfully,
truth is your best bet if you're too agreeable.
So you know,
you also might find that you have a pretty good critical intelligence,
but that you think it's mean and so that you keep it hidden.
Some of the smartest women I knew who were very,
very agreeable had unbelievably good instincts with regards to figuring out what
other people's motives were,
but they were ashamed of their suspicions.
And really what that meant was they ended up being ashamed of their critical
intelligence because they were so agreeable.
So it may be that the darker part of you,
the shadow part of you knows things that you could know if you are willing to
admit that they were true.
And so you have to give some credence to your,
to your darker element,
I would say.
How do you know if you were communicating with the actual person or a mask?
I sometimes wonder if I can ever really know someone.
Well,
you can't ever thoroughly know someone because people are too complicated.
You can't even really know yourself.
How do you know if you're communicating with the actual person or a mask?
Well,
if you're communicating with an actual person,
then you're actually having a conversation,
you know,
and the conversation transforms as a consequence of participating in it and it
tends to be engaging in meaningful.
If what's happening is an exchange of ideological platitudes or or just
platitudes themselves for that matter,
then you probably engaging with the mask.
So if the conversation is compelling and meaningful and it transforms as it as
it progresses and and you can see that give and take that dance like give and
take,
then you're communicating with an actual person.
The other thing I would say is that when you're communicating with an actual
person rather than a mask,
that person that you're communicating with tends to be quite interesting.
You know,
if people talk about what they know,
which means you really communicating with them.
If they talk about their own personal experience instead of wandering off into
the domain of cliches and ideological platitudes,
then people tend to be extraordinarily interesting.
And so that's another good tactic and a good hint that you're,
that you're where you should be when you're conversing.
One of the rules I had when I was seeing clients actively was that if the
conversation I was having wasn't interesting,
and if my attention started to wonder,
then we weren't discussing issues that were sufficiently vital because if we
were discussing vital issues,
then the conversation basically flew by,
and so I think that's a good,
that's a good marker.